welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of House of
the Dragon episode 6. where our cast
grows up so fast the kids are not all
right and ladybug lyrics is loose so
much to break down no time to waste
let's get started and really the first
thing to point out HBO's new banner
poster for this series features Olivia
Cook and Emma Darcy with the giant
dragon vegar behind them its golden eye
has the iris slit in the shape of aegon
the conqueror's dagger a dagger that
will literally come between these two
women next episode now since we've
jumped forward 10 years the opening
titles bloodline imagery has a ton of
updates where before we saw viserys and
Emma's dials now we see Allison Style on
the Hightower green side in the bar
background with four branches sneaking
down for her children aegon Helena
aemond and we don't see him in this
episode but there is a fourth kid on the
way at least Darren in the foreground we
see a new bloodline flowing into a new
dial for Damon Targaryen depicting his
Dragon winged helmet blood flows from
that to a blue color dial behind him
which we then see in close-up depicting
the brain of lyanna valarian Damon's new
wife her bloodline flows to two blue
ring dials with dragon eggs in each for
their twin daughters Rihanna and Bayla
the dial depicting rhaenyra's Valyrian
steel necklace now branches off toward
an engraving depicting dragons over a
fleet but major detail here her
bloodline is connecting with another
dial on the far right and that is not a
valarian dial that is a dial of Sir
Harwin break bones strong with the three
rivers of the how strong sigil
representing the green red and blue
Forks of the Trident because obviously
Renaissance earnhardwin's kids and this
River of Blood also Forks into three
just saris or Jace luceris or Luke and
Joffrey or Joff all three of these have
a pale blue ring since they are
valarion's name but their symbols are
all their own and will have greater
significance as this story unfolds
Miguel sapochnic return to direct this
episode since with the new cast it's
pretty much a second pilot for the
series whereas episode 1 featured Emma's
tragic childbirth sequence this episode
opens with Ramirez and notice some
punchnik shoots this in an excruciating
unbroken three minute take throwing
might have hidden a cut in the quick
pans or when something breaks the frame
but still this tape followed immediately
by another two minute 40 second tracking
Shot Through The Castle as the effect of
centering us on raniera's pain
delivering that child and then
immediately having to go on a long walk
all the way to the Queen's chamber if
you think about it the reason we're near
does this walk is she knows who the
father is she knows Allison wants to
check the hair color and she does not
want to part ways with this baby in case
its hair color exposes him and her other
two sons to the sword she's not taking
any chances and really these opening
minutes occur in real time with the new
Prince Joffrey's life in this world we
open on black Aussie crowns and we see
how he spends roughly the first eight
minutes of his life last episode ended
with the death of one Joffrey this
episode opens with the birth of the boy
named after him but the moment the baby
comes out notice the nurse maid's
reaction boy princess
yeah her face says it all she's reacting
to the color of the boy's hair a dark
brown like both of his older brothers
because as his nurse made knows this is
another bastard and more Royal drama to
follow now one of the things I love most
about fantasy is the Epic scope of
everything you're not just facing off
against another Knight for your honor
the fate of the Rome is at stake of
course in my day-to-day life this takes
a much smaller like whether or not I
could fit another Gimli figure out on my
collectible shelf now obviously that's
super exciting but sometimes what you
really need are those big Epic Fantasy
level stakes and that's when I bust out
my phone to play Lord of the Rings rise
to war Lord of the Rings rise to war
puts you in the middle of Middle Earth
controlling vast armies to conquer doll
goldur and claim the ring Lord of the
Rings rise to war has all of my favorite
parts of strategy simulation games
there's a strategy involved in how you
gather your resources how you manage
your resources and which factions and
fellowships you join to increase your
power little decisions like which
Commander to pair with which army or
which resource tile to acquire next can
make huge decision is on a grand scale
it's so much deeper than just being
Unstoppable in the battlefield and
that's what really sets Lord of the
Rings The Rise To War apart from other
strategy simulation games and that's on
top of appearances from Aragorn Kimberly
like a list and a ton of other my
favorite characters from The Lord of the
Rings this is the best time to get
started in The Lord of the Rings rise to
war and if you use the link in the
description or scan this QR code you'll
get a limited Hobbit's Adventure package
hit the link and support new rockstars
by downloading this game it's that easy
just click the link in the description
and I will see you in Middle Earth
renera and leonors walk through the
castle again a nearly three-minute
unbroken shot is impressive mostly
because it shows how large of an
interior set they actually built for
this show with a grand staircase that
actually leads to a higher level which
is really rare in TV shows normally the
series just kind of go to nowhere and
then they cut to a different set where
they're upstairs but sapochnik wanted to
inhabit this set properly and introduce
the characters at an older age by four
sets to spend some time with them the
moment renira gives birth until she
meets Alison was not in the original
script and I thought well if we're gonna
have this set I would like us to inhabit
it properly which is why the opening
actually follows our characters in a
single continuous take all the way
through
hey Lord Caswell congratulates them if I
may be of any service today May yet come
my Lord yeah cast well we'll play an
important role in the conflict to come
as a supporter of renero so she will
call in that favor and guarding the
Queen's door is Sir Kristen Cole who
inexplicably managed to keep his job in
the King's Guard despite murdering
someone on these two's wedding day
including assaulting the groom which
just goes to show how little the crown
really cared about Leonor and his Knight
of kisses and really goes to show how
powerful Allison has become the fact
they have to pass so Kristen at the
doorway here likely is what led to land
or naming that boy Joffrey after the
geyser Kristen killed it almost seems
out of impulse to force the queen and
her bodyguard to remember this name King
viserys joins them looking like mid
Montage smeagle one hand short of the
Comfort level I would need to give a
newborn to
fine Prince
sturdy
you will make a fearsome night sturdy or
another word for strong outside this
chambers of Kristen now has us back to
them as they pass the ultimate cold
shoulder radera says you don't
so maybe we name my child
our child is he not
right here saying Leonor has not been
interested in her Affairs as of late
yeah not exactly subtle neither is the
literal trail of blood leading back to
Kristen and the queen just a reminder
that those blood rivers in the opening
titles aren't just about succession
they're about the Bloodshed that comes
with it Rainier finds her sons Jason
Luke back with their real father sir
Harwin we chose a knife for the baby
[Music]
that looks like the perfect one I like
luches thank you yes yeah a little thank
you from the younger brother to the
older and the way that the older brother
grabs his brother's hand to keep him
from getting burned these boys aren't
total shits at least not yet there's
just something to be said for mixing
non-vellerian DNA into this bloodline in
the dragon pit Jace meets his Dragon
Vermax whom he and the dragon Keepers
command with High Valyrian words like um
boss meaning hold into hyrus meaning
serve as in valade's all men must serve
you'll notice Allison has dressed her
sons in Hightower green whereas
rhaenyra's Sons wear valarian blue but
none of these kids were the Targaryen
colors of red and black Jay successfully
binds with Vermax who torches a lamb now
aegon is already binded with his Dragon
Sunfire and Jace's younger brother Luke
has already binded with the dragon that
goes unmentioned here but in the text
it's RX so as the oldest who's gone
through this a couple times aegon yawn
said Vermax and it is clearly his idea
to prank aemon with the pink dread a
play on the Dragon valerion the black
dread so eamon's humiliated wanders
deeper into the pit where he runs into a
chain of dragon and right as a dragon
begin tends to breathe fire you can see
its scales are a pale blue color this
dragon is dreamfire the bluish silver
she Dragon whose eggs Damon stole one of
in episode two this is a dragon that
will bind with eamon's sister Helena we
meet Elena who is a case filled with
beetles and moths and scorpions and she
fawns of her millipede it has eyes I
don't believe it can see and why is that
same do you think it is beyond your
understanding that's I suppose you're
right something's just dark yeah this
series is doing something different with
Elena than in the text I think we're
gonna learn that Helena is a green Seer
and or a ward you remember green Sears
like the three-eyed Raven they can see
into the future Worx can transplant
their minds and animals both are
associated with the magic of the
children of the forest and the faces in
the weirwood trees are believed to be
how the green Sears are able to do their
Green Scene just notice how Helena's
words are deeply prophetic amen
what have you done he did it again they
said they found a dragon for me the last
ring has no legs at all you will have a
dragon one day
he'll have to close an eye I know it
yeah book readers know what he'll have
to close an eye refers to and we're
gonna see it next episode but I think
the last ring having no legs could be a
reference to the green Seer King brand
the broken a kid who Helena would get
along great with because Helena says
that each ring has two legs 60 Rings
creating hundreds of legs which I think
is a metaphor for each generation of
rulers needing a king and a queen the
bloodline being the leg to the next
Branch as every episode of the series
has begun by showing us this line of
succession is going to continue to the
last ring of the story bran someone who
cannot walk and Sansa says that he
cannot bear children therefore the wheel
or in this case the ring is broken Elena
says the millipede has eyes but cannot
see and I think that's just her way of
saying these rulers are cursed with
literalized but don't have the proper
vision of green sight but she likely
does and so does brand and maybe so do
others in this story remember Helena's
Dragon will be dream fire and I think
she inherited the Targaryen skill of
azera's wishes he inherited from his
ancestor Dane East the dreamer in this
case it is Helena the dreamer viserys's
pathetic model train set of valyria has
expanded now with various structures
topped with stone dragons like the one
Allison gifted the king I love how
sapotronic frames that v-shaped inserted
the tall structure so that a background
torch is perfectly framed in the valley
of it creating the illusion of a volcano
like one of the volcanoes that destroyed
old valyria Allison questions the
parentage of Rainier's sons and viserys
sends away a stonemason who's named
edard a metanata Edward Stark in Game of
Thrones who spent most episodes on a
paternity Crusade of his own that also
involved a bastard named Joffrey Allison
says to have one child like that is a
mistake death three is an insult and as
she says this notice the hills of
aegon's dagger is right by her hand her
shadow in a move she will make with that
dagger next episode to act on this
suspicion but viserys refuses to see the
truth he Compares this to a black horse
he once had that bred with a white
stallion as silver as the moon on a
Winter's Night reduced in the fall the
color chestnut nature is a thing of
mysterious works yeah you can't see it
parallel with his expectation of a
silver wide stag just to find an
unremarkable brown one I think that was
the episode when we really gave up on
trying to read into science importance
sir Kristen calls Rainier the c word and
Allison says
that in the end on a indecency will
prevail followed by the most ironic jump
cut to aegon making a mess out the
window ah the things we do for love and
the fact that Ellison doesn't really
react to him doing this suggests that he
might be doing this all the time but
really the bigger concern for Allison is
the preservation of her bloodline you
are the challenge you are the challenge
aegon simply by living and breathing the
way all of their dials are pre-engraved
into the stone and the opening credits
shows how these characters are really
destined to be in conflict with their
relatives the moment the bloodline flows
into them they don't really have much
control over what's ahead over in pintos
Damon rides his Dragon character's but
finds himself with a shadow of a much
larger one vegar written by Lana who
actually referenced vegar in episode two
but Vegas lives
somewhere
but too large for the dragon pit the
walk is a spice Town report during her
song at times
they say it's a sad thing yeah vegar sad
song might foreshadow the dragons
repeated losing of her lady writers if
you think about it Leanna's first and
final word of this episode is jakaris
vegar is the largest living Dragon
currently who was once written by the
zenya aegon the conqueror's sister wife
notice how vegar's Wings have holes in
them from old age and I love how they
just used a scale of lyanna's body on
Big R saddle compared to demon on his
saddle just to convey veigar's Mid-City
Prince Reggio jaratus says lamb hearts
are excellent yeah remind us of that
roasted lamb heart that the dragon
Vermax ate earlier we learned that the
triarchy has joined forces with Dorne
and Reggio once their Three Dragons for
defense Damon considers it but Lana
doesn't want to be used we are not
minstrels and Mummers who play at the
pleasure of an alien Prince we are the
blood of old valyria Mummers it's
essentially what they were earlier
putting on a dragon buyer's show for the
crowd and Damon may be remembering his
own two small parts and the Mummers play
back in King's land in episode 4. sir
Kristen oversees a sparring session in
the yard with the boys after his
mother's warning notice how aegon has
gone from yawning to swinging hard on
that dummy J's shoulder checks Eamonn
and aegon Pats Luke on the shoulder it's
an interesting contrast in the status
and respect among these four kids aegon
the oldest and Luke the youngest of the
four were the first two to bind with
Dragons leaving Jason Eamonn with this
rivalry both of them avoiding being the
last one to bind to a dragon sir Kristen
puts Jace and aegon together eldest son
against eldest son yeah Lionel's
reaction says it all he knows Jason Luke
are secretly his grandsons he doesn't
really like how sir Christian is setting
up conflict putting it on display for
everybody during their fight aegon
shoves the dummy over on Jay's Foul Play
I'll deal with him
yeah well you're sir Kristen's advice to
aegon but not what sir Harwin says to
Jace we never want to get suspicious so
sir Kristen takes it out on Jace by
letting aegon go crazy on him and when
sir Harman complains about it he
dickishly drops his sparring sword for
hormone to have to reach over again to
pick it up and Sir Kristen tons Harwin
most men would only have that kind of
devotion toward a cousin
or brother
or a son kingon's hair is blocking his
face but he is flashing a wide grin
under there and his heart when it's
dragged away from punching Kristen aegon
continues to smile in shock showing how
this kid is old enough to get the
subtext and it's probably going to
continue to use this against his cousins
Leonor comes in singing with sir Carl
Corey who immediately sobers up when he
sees renera in the room because Carl
probably knows what happened to the last
of lenor's male lovers when he or
stepped this guy is a smarter head on
his shoulders and job read it to just
keep an eye on him Leonard drunkenly
rants about the chance to fight in the
stepstones he says there is a Thai roshi
General there a giant they say dies his
beard purple and wears women's frocks
yes this tairoshi General is recalio
rendoon described by George R Martin as
one of the most curious and flamboyant
Rogues in the animals of History I don't
think we're gonna meet him on the show
but I'm glad he got mentioned Lana
Shane's demon you spend your time here
in the library reading accounts of the
same dead Dragon Lords whose Legacy you
claim has no hold on you didn't know I
was being so minutely observed remember
earlier Lana caught him teaching bail at
how to speak High Valyrian so despite
his prodigal Exile in pintos his Dragon
Legacy keeps calling him back at the
small council meeting both rhaenyra and
Allison now join each with their own
punch card ball they discuss a dispute
between the brackets the blackwoods and
the riverlands those are the long
warring families whose young Lords
dueled at Storm's end at the beginning
of episode 4. they mentioned Lord Grover
Tully George R Martin actually named
Lord Grover after the Muppet Grover
along with Grover's grandson Elmo and
great grandsons Kermit and Oscar I'm not
kidding those are actually their names
Allison wants to leave this as a local
matter but renira presses on and yet the
brackens and the blackwoods will use any
excuse to spit each other's blood this
dispute bears looking into there will be
country folk who know where the lines
have been drawn for Generations
that is easy enough
yeah I already
difference in the leadership
stuff one wants to be Hands-On a
preemptive deal with problems
immediately one is a more passive leader
once
this complex Lionel tries to move on to
Tyler Lannister stepstones report but he
still reacts to Allison's hostility and
poor old Lyman beesberry just struggles
to keep up to me I think the blackwoods
have the upper hand no we've moved on to
the steps Towing slow beesbury yeah we
got a new Arch maester or a while just
saw him last episode he was the kid then
who recommended an herbal remedy to
Melos the fact that Melos has gone now
might actually be the reason viserys has
been alive the past 10 years and still
able to walk because he was not looking
good at the last episode because it just
shows that it was really melos's
treatment that was holding back the new
master of laws is Jasper Wilde nicknamed
iron Rod some say because of his
unyielding respect to the rule of law
some say because he's sired 29 kids
Rainier stands to apologize and while
all the others sit Allison does not
Rainer offers Alison to marry Jace to
Helena really the nicest of her boys to
the Green Scene bug girl a niece to a
bastard Uncle not great not terrible and
for Dragon Cyrax gives more eggs she
offers The Game and his choice of them
so Allison's response is really grounded
in stubbornness and a personal Grudge
toward Rainier instead of hearing her
out she shuts her down as a hormonal
mother
when era
Allison says to viserys she feels the
Earth washing away beneath her feet so
now she expects us to ignore her
transgressions and for me to marry my
only daughter to one of her
playing featured Sons yeah she almost
said to one of her bastards and she goes
on he made as you wish husband
well I am cold in
staircase railing separates this married
couple in the frame Lyle strong tries to
resign but refuses to verbalize his
reasoning Allison passes a mate Who
giggles at her when she passes Allison
probably sees this as another reason to
feel paranoid the whole Crown is
laughingstock now that the strong rumors
are going around we learned that Lord
Lara's strong has been sort of a master
of Whispers for the queen learning that
his father and brother are headed to
harrenhal he recruits a murderer a
deviant and a traitor to the crown for a
mission his Cane is marked with his
sigil which according to HBO's prop
listing is a firefly they actually
designed this cane head so that it looks
like the Firefly is stuck in tree sap
kind of like John Hammond's Amber Kane
in Jurassic Park ooh to little Jolly
flea circus you've created lordberis
span no moral expense now if hilarious
is so smart I don't know why he'd show
his face to these criminals instead of
using like a middleman or why he'd Mark
these arsonists with brooches of the
same Firefly sigil on his Cane I mean
Montana struggles to give birth and the
surgeon says
by way of the blade but I cannot say for
a surety whether it lives or the mother
surviving
Atlanta hears this and she pushes away
intent
she orders vegar to jakaris giving
herself a dragon Rider's death Harwin
says combined the boys into renera
[Music]
now he means a stranger to this boy but
it's also a signal that he's about to
meet the stranger the one of the seven
who represents death Jace cuts to the
chase he's tall and strong my father am
I a bastard
you are a Targaryen
of course he doesn't say yes or no but
she's pretty much signaling to Jace the
truth because renera has given up trying
to keep this secret she tells later that
they are leaving on a Midnight Train to
Dragonstone but she tells him he can
bring sir Carl ooh in the scene by
sliding the dagger in its sheet Lionel
and Harwin strong burn alive in
harrenhal which was a mystery in the
book that readers have ascribed to Damon
maybe the ghost of harrenhal but now we
learn it was orchestrated by Laris and
his Firefly mutes his voice over posits
that children are a weakness a way for
people to try to form a legacy beyond
death but It ultimately leads people to
make poor choices
what is the right thing to be done but
love stays the hand
love is a downfall maybe there's just me
rereading Fellowship of the Ring right
now but this reminds me of an exchange
between Gandalf and Frodo about Gollum
Frodo says what's a Pity that Bilbo did
not stab that vile creature when he had
a chance and Gandalf responds perjure it
was pitching that straight his hand
could you in Mercy not to strike without
need and he goes on to say my heart
tells me that here's some part to play
yet but go to Ill before the end and
when that comes the pity of Bilbo May
rule the fate of many yours not least
the idea is similar here Lara says love
stays the hand and that because of love
people make blind choices that shape the
fates of many this series is at its
heart about how love stays the hand and
Dooms us all but that ultimately is just
a mysterious nature of things the
closing Montage shows the Bert remains
of Lana and Harwin renira's lover and
Damon's lover the lovers standing in
their ways toward each other both
claimed by fire vizara still holds on to
Emma's ring and he kisses it on his
finger but he sees the rats spying on
him from this room this rat keeps
showing up again and again you spying on
rhenera from layering the black dread as
she snuck out of the castle he spied on
Allison from her bedpost he was weirdly
sipping on Joffrey's blood during
Rainier and leonor's wedding at the end
last episode YouTuber Joe the magician
posted a fascinating theory that Lara
strong might be a Warg or a green Seer
Laris somehow knew that the archmaester
brought Rainier the T Laris might be
working into that rat to spy on everyone
and gather this information he did have
that meaningful moment with Allison by
the weirdwood tree and their home of
harrenhal is situated beside the God's
eye Lake which has the Isle of faces in
the middle that contains a Grove of
weirwood trees it is a hugely
spiritually significant location of The
Song of Ice and Fire lore that we have
yet to visit in live action and I think
we actually see that Island in this
episode in the wide shot of harrenhal
leris's Sigil of the Firefly could
connect with Helena's interest in
insects maybe something he instilled in
her as he nurtures her Green Scene
abilities to top it all off the writer
of this episode Sarah Hess actually said
about Laris in the inside the episode
featurette he's a player and he's
looking into the future and seeing
seeing what she is going to be later
since this episode bottling that same
red flower from braavos that he brought
up to Allison the godswood last episode
talking about how an outside species of
flower could grow so well here inside
the castle we thought he was referring
to Allison really he was referring to
himself how he is growing strong on one
hand this Series has a clear destination
of the well-documented dance of the
dragons and which Targaryen is going to
win it all at the end which of them are
gonna die but on a deeper layer is some
additional Lord mythology that's not
really touched on Fire and Blood and I'm
so excited to explore that this show is
doing a good job keeping both people who
read the book and didn't read the book
invest it you can follow me on Tick Tock
Instagram and Twitter at eavos follow me
rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
foreign
[Music]